now remember what Obama described us
conservatives as bitter people clinging
to our guns and our religion well now we
see who the real bitter clingers really
are schiff schumer Nadler pelosi romney
bolton just to name a few well all of
them when you think about it in their
own way are very angry people they cling
reflexively to an ideology that most
people just don't relate to anymore now
the democrats have become increasingly
rabid and radical
they're turning off most sane people
Boulton though he's a poster child for
the neocon never Trump crowd still
fantasizing about the glory days of
deploying a hundred thousand troops for
nation building in Iraq both left and
right have rejected his interventionist
worldview yet somehow he landed the NSC
job at the Trump White House go figure
well fortunate for us President Trump
was too smart to fall for all that
nonsense a blank check for any country
claiming to be an ally with a hand
stretched out not the Trump doctrine
baby and that's for MIT can I get a
witness Romney well he's bitter too he
still can't believe someone of his
pedigree and upbringing ever lost the
presidency and that a man like Trump
wanted 2012 is over mitt don't punish
Trump or the rest of us for your own
weakness as a candidate now last night I
titled the angle 24 hours to victory
love that font
well that title is correct though
because Trump today triumphed over the
unfair unjust and politically motivated
witch-hunt but the Democrats cannot
accept defeat as we've told you time and
again when they lose they call
everything that happened before
illegitimate but now even the liberal
media well they're having a hard time
spinning it
Trump won he's gonna win this trial he
he won on the issue of witnesses he's
going to get acquitted that's how the
history will remember what went on here
it's over they lost
Trump one Toobin even has to admit it so
let's move on but no that would be the
gracious thing to do instead the
democrats are dragging it out in a
pathetic attempt to cast a pall over
trump state of the union address and to
gratuitously ruin Super Bowl weekend for
the rest of us Oh the Iowa caucuses who
cares about those now schumer the gang
are deeply bitter selfish and
self-aggrandizing people they're bitter
once again because Trump has beaten them
at their own game and once again Mitch
McConnell that sly wily old dog of the
Senate outmaneuvered all of them and
once again some of the radicals and
their party are just repelling the
public and the support of key senators
they needed senator Murkowski was so
turned off by Elizabeth Warren's stunt
demeaning the Chief Justice with a
question last night that she rejected
witnesses because of it she wrote I will
not stand for nor support that effort so
while Chuck and Adam tilt at windmills
President Trump what has he done
well he's chalked up some fantastic
victories this week the US MCA and a
bold Middle East peace plan name a
couple and his administration is
managing a global contagion that is
threatening lives and international
markets he also signed an executive
order to dismantle some of the world's
worst criminal enterprises my
administration is fighting these
monsters persecuting and prosecuting
them and locking them away for a very
very long time
we are dismantling the criminal
organizations that make large-scale
human trafficking possible but the
political games are not over not by a
long shot now I warned you the other
night that the Democrats in the media
would drop one shiny object after
another and do it in front of us as an
attempt to kind of drag this out as long
as possible well Julie sweat Nick is
some hair waiting in the wings and right
on cue of course the New York Times
conveniently dropped the number another
11th hour exclusive fed by sources who
claimed
have read Jon Bolton's unpublished
manuscript the significance of this
can't be understated Bolton seems to
implicate all of the players suddenly
there is new information that involves
Pat's Apolo knees actually being in a
room where supposedly some of this
happens this it absolutely disgusts me
this is essentially the end of clue the
butler did it in the Oval Office you
know with a hatchet now it's obvious to
anyone with a pulse that this is nothing
more than a calculated anonymously
sourced hit job it's a last-ditch
attempt to sway fence sitting senators
but Adam Schiff wants you to believe it
is gospel you will recall mr. sip Aloni
suggesting that the house managers were
concealing facts from this body he said
all the facts should come out well
there's a new fact which indicates that
mr. Salone was among those who are in
the loop just as we predicted and it
didn't require any great act of
clairvoyance the facts would come out
he'll never mind that the president has
already issued a blanket statement
saying the meeting never happened
so Schiff is gonna do anything though to
keep this hustle alive what else does he
have even if it means tarnishing the
reputation of good men like Pat's
abalone now Schiff knows he's lost and
he knows that he and all the Democrats
are grasping at any claim no matter how
tenuous the string to fake you know this
impeachment keep it going keep it going
keep it going
Chuck Schumer by the way it's already
refusing to accept the results of the
next election unless of course something
happens between now and Wednesday and
Trump is just removed from office if
this president is interfering in the
elections the elections may not have a
fair result very few people doubt that
he would do it again and again and again
he's already tried several times he's
done it several times this from a man by
the way who supports striking Trump's
name from the ballot in November while
forcing major candidates in his own
party
off the campaign trail just days before
the Iowa caucuses and Trump is the one
interfering with the elections no Chuck
it's you and chip and the entire
Democrat gang who are putting your
fingers on the scale for the Democrat
establishment good luck but the American
people see right through you and that's
the angle